and then I get a call from the nurse and
she says your wife is about to deliver I
said what are you talking about so she
goes your wife's about to go into labor
I was like okay bye I'm literally in the
parking lot so I have like a huge duffel
bag I'm running to the ER which is on
the opposite side of the hospital the
security guard was outside being like
cuz they told him just to let me in cuz
my wife was going into labor I'm going
up to the elevator there's like a secure
door an intercom and a camera and you
have to push the button to get allowed
in so I'm pushing the button nothing
pushing pushing pushing pushing I was
probably there for 2 minutes and I see
someone who works there just cruising in
so I run over there I was like yo
somebody let me in and then one of the
nurses hear me she says are you uh Mrs
Klein's husband I said yeah she goes
okay she's right in that she's right in
there and I start walking up and I hear
a baby crying I was like no freaking way
I walk in the room and there's Ela and
the baby and all the doctors she gave
birth 2 minutes before I got there